all right Lush what's going on Lush you
uh you're actually on uh another Channel
on YouTube you're on yes no jumper right
yes sir oh you've been there been a no
jumper for a little bit
about like seven months but recently
it's been with a lot more frequency and
I've been added to the the main podcast
which has been pretty cool but I've been
you know I've been on YouTube for
several years
hosting rap battles and you know as a
hip-hop artist as well tell me where you
grew up west side of Los Angeles
like the real West Side the real west
side I mean it depends on who you talk
to that's right there's varying
definitions of what the west side is if
you talk to gang members it's anything
west of the 110 and then there's West
Side South Central if you talk to
affluent white people they think it's
everything west of the 405 but
right but I'm you know literally the
Sawtelle District of West Los Angeles
near Palms is where I grew up and tell
me about your family growing up in
Baldwin Hills and all that uh my family
uh my dad's a filmmaker
um my mom was a producer as well of
plays basically for as far back as my
lineage goes it's all people in
entertainment and activism
um and you know like my parents marched
on Washington back in the day and all
that
um it's kind of crazy because my parents
I have two older brothers they're 12 and
14 years older than me so essentially it
was like
having two uncles and they both left the
house when I was really um
and uh
um my parents were like around my age
now they're like 40 when they had me so
I think they kind of expected to have
they already knew how to raise kids they
had it all figured out this third kid
was just going to be easy and a breeze
to take care of and it was kind of what
wound up happening was the polar
opposite of that
you finish High School I did graduate
high school by the grace of God I'm
wound up getting expelled it was banned
from LAUSD was expelled from three
different high schools and I wound up
graduating from a school
um which was basically like if your
parents had it was like half special
needs half like of your parents cared
enough about your future in education
they will put you here and you're damn
near guaranteed a high school diploma on
top of that I was also
um Sleeping with the secretary she was
like my same age we were both 18 and she
gave me answers to a lot of the finals
that helps yeah but I mean like the the
school the graduating class was like 15
kids it was a it was like they allowed
us to smoke cigarettes in the front it's
crazy because the the school it was
actually in the valley it was like near
the Sherman Oaks Van Nuys border and now
it formerly was a dentist office before
I went there and then when I you know
after I graduated like 15 years later
whatever it's now like a medical
cannabis dispensary and uh I was like
that's crazy they're selling weed there
now because I was doing it
[ __ ] 15 years ago how would you how
would you describe your childhood in
general
um I come from a loving home my parents
were very attentive although my dad was
gone a lot working so I spent a lot of
time outside and alone and just
kind of like intermingling with the kids
in the neighborhood and all that so
it was for the most part pretty good
though but you took a different path
then you're
the rest of your family very different
path they're all like hyper achievers
my oldest brother he had you know he was
a drug addict as well
but he got sober when he was 20 years
old and like the height of his addiction
was
you know he almost got expelled
from Princeton he was went to an Ivy
League school and like that was as I I
don't want to undermine his struggles
because he definitely went through it
but you know ever since then his his
life has been and even before then prior
to like his two or three years of
getting [ __ ] up he has just like a
pretty Charmed existence and he's very
very successful my other brother wound
up you know following in my dad's
footsteps and being a filmmaker and me
like you know I'm kind of been a
Perpetual disappointment in the black
sheep of the family
what do you think that is
is it genetic is it something that you
went through
um well you know there's I suffered a
lot of abuse
um at an early age that I wasn't really
aware of until it was identified years
later
um
there was so when I was like five years
old there was a babysitter a female
babysitter that um put hands on me in a
sexual way and um there's a couple
similar incidents to that
um when I was
a teenager I was
I slept um slept with a woman I was
seduced by a woman that was a lot older
than me she was like in her late 30s and
a lot of people hear that and be like oh
that's cool like you got laid what do
you mean but it wasn't like a woman that
I would normally ever pursue or choose
to sleep with and she like kind of
prayed on me and got me drunk and you
know there's several incidents like that
even there's a little girl that I used
to play with and I when I was around
that same age like four or five years
old
um
and uh I think she must have been abused
as well because when I would be when I
would like go over to her house like she
would kind of like we'd play like games
for you know it was there's a whole
bunch of things that happened to me I
don't know if that's the sole reason I
became an addict but that definitely is
something through therapy that I've
identified years later this is my first
time ever actually speaking on it and
it's you know something that I'm kind of
embarrassed about and feel
self-conscious about but yeah it's
something you're out of your control
though something completely out of my
control but you know my dad being gone a
lot me being essentially outside
um my mom not being able to control me
when my when my brothers were raised in
the west side of La in the 70s it was a
much more idyllic time and and in
California and there there wasn't the
gang infestation there wasn't you know
this prior to the Ronald Reagan crack
cocaine era and all that and you know
like it was a much safer place to live
and I was kind of coming of age in a
dangerous time in the city during the
you know the the LA riots and all these
extreme racial tension and all this
crazy [ __ ] and I was kind of outside
thrusting the midst of it and I never
really my mom wasn't able to get me to
come home I wouldn't listen to her my
dad would come home after being gone for
several months and try to like assert
some type of authority I wasn't really
trying to hear it
um you know wound up falling in with a
crowd that you know was uh started doing
speedy and you know my little crew
became a gang and all that at a you know
during my early teen years I got
arrested for the first time I first I
got started getting [ __ ] up when I was
12 just smoking and drinking
um a lot of kids my and it was normal
for kids my age where I was from at that
time to be already like sexually active
trying to holler at girls and stuff I I
was trying to I didn't wasn't able to
get laid until I was like 14 but I was
definitely trying to at that age before
I could even like really bust a nut or
anything you know um I I got arrested
for the first time at 13 drinking 40s in
an alley in Westwood behind the in and
out
um
16 I wound up getting arrested
and um this is in 1998 and I got caught
for I was basically trying I was
basically trying to tag up a building
but they said
um vandalism
trespassing and I had three dime bags of
wheat on me so they said possession with
intent to distribute was I going to sell
it or smoke it I mean it doesn't really
matter like probably both but at that
time you know marijuana was far more
stigmatized so they considered that
those three counts and try to give me a
felony but instead of sending me off to
a regular Juvenile Facility they sent me
to a place called Anacapa by the Sea if
you're between 35 and 45 years old and
um were an adolescent in Los Angeles and
had a lot of severe drug problems you
might know about Anacapa a lot of people
got sent there it was it wound up
getting shut down by the state of
California but it was a full lockdown
Juvenile Facility but it was had like a
heavy emphasis on substance abuse and
things like that and um that kind of
became drug boot camp for me and I was
perpetuated my addiction significantly
in addition to that like you know I got
my first serious girlfriend who was
um a run a runaway who was suicidal
um she ran away from her home in
Westchester with her boyfriend and they
went all the way up to Seattle they
wound up getting arrested sent back down
to Anacapa and before we met and fell in
love like the most I wouldn't even say
we were soul mates for more like scar
mates essentially and um
and she kind of had me flipping my whole
script she was like Gothic and [ __ ] so
I'm like damn I gotta I gotta like enter
her world so I started like I've always
been a hip-hop head but I started
listening to like Nine Inch Nails and
skinny puppy and trying to like you know
get into more like Gothic things and
[ __ ] to um
to keep her attention she was really
really beautiful she wound up being like
in the original Suicide Girls book a few
years later when she was old enough to
which was I always thought it was tight
like my first girlfriend was an OG
Suicide Girl um
uh shortly after then I wound up getting
expelled from high school and then had a
series of expulsions like the first time
I I got expelled I was already on like
triple probation and the only reason
they hadn't expelled me yet because my
mom was super active in the PTA and
things like that and uh I got caught
doing graffiti on our different schools
campus and all this other [ __ ] but they
didn't expel me but I wound up getting
um one of getting
you know Happy Days you know the funds
the funds his son he was like a freshman
and I was a junior and uh there's a lot
of Hollywood kids that went to the
school I went to at the time and uh I
thought it would be funny to get him
drunk so I got him drunk for his first
time doing during uh lunch time came
back
kid puked in art class wound up
snitching me out I get expelled
went to UNI High wound up getting caught
smoking weed
right basically adjacent to the campus
got expelled from there
and uh the rest of my high school was
pretty dysfunctional like all different
kinds of
crime like I was you know hitting a lot
of licks
um
even like some car theft all kinds of
crazy [ __ ] that I'm lucky to have never
really got caught up for
um wound up between
the ages of 16 and 19 though I was in
like 10 different treatment centers
um
when I was 18 I was supposed to it was
like the summer before I'm supposed to
go to college
and my dad was making a film overseas
I'd been
selling ecstasy before that and popping
a lot of ecstasy like on a daily basis
not like just partying with it I'd like
wake up in the morning and pop an e-pill
and [ __ ] like that it was kind of
crucial I was dating this this Russian
girl
over there in West Hollywood she's
saying on a in an apartment and on
Sunset in poinsettia and you know she
was like a big drug dealer I used to
hang out with all the Russians over
there and she was also a prostitute but
I didn't know it at the time because I'm
like was kind of naive and went behind
the ears and I was like yeah when we'd
be around other people she'd be like you
can't tell them that I'm your girlfriend
and I didn't know that that was abnormal
I was just always been so
desperate for acceptance and really
wanted
a relationship so bad that's all I
wanted that's all I cared about and it's
never seemed to materialize but uh that
summer my dad was making a film in a
country called Luxembourg have you ever
heard of Luxembourg before it's like a
historically nameless blip of a nation
in between France Germany and Holland
and uh what it is is essentially it's a
place where people go to watch their
money it's the whole country is like a
bank and you see like people pull up in
limos hop out with an attache case walk
into the bank
um and I don't know what the [ __ ]
they're doing but my pops is making a
movie out there and I um went out to
visit him and when I was out there I
wound up
having an overdose on ecstasy and uh I
was in my so basically I'd taken
I'd pop some pills the night before and
I'm supposed to meet up with my parents
for brunch
the following morning and uh I I went to
bed or whatever woke up and I was
feeling really sick like abnormal I I
I'm used to feeling the after effects of
being on Ecstasy but this [ __ ] felt a
lot different and I couldn't quite put
my finger on it but I was like I
remember calling my mom like I'm
supposed to meet at like 1 p.m or like
11 I forget what time I'd be like hey
Mom like I'm gonna be a little late
could we like delayed an hour she's like
okay honey and like it's about to be
another hour and I'm like I'm still I'm
feeling worse and worse and worse our
hearts leaping out my chest I don't know
what the [ __ ] going on I call again
like Mom I'm gonna need to can we push
it back a little more I'm still not
feeling that good and she's like all
right like starting to get a little bit
suspicious they've are they're already
like they don't know what to do with me
I've been terrorizing their existence
you know for several years at this point
but they're just they're just hoping I
go to college for some reason they think
that if I make it and I survive this
period and go away to college everything
will be okay I don't know why they had
that idea in their head maybe because
they knew I needed to get the [ __ ] out
of La which was true but for some reason
um they're just like
they can't control me but then I'm
feeling worse and worse and worse I call
my mom again it's time to meet up and
she's like come the [ __ ] down right now
and I remember like I'm starting to like
lose
like there's like spatial distortions
um I have no equilibrium I remember
looking at the mirror at myself and
really all I could see is my own
bloodshot palpitating eyes staring back
at myself next thing I remember
apparently I made my way to the elevator
and uh passed out like fainted or
whatever in the lobby I wake up and
there's a bunch of people speaking some
like crucial foreign language over me
like while they're Reviving me
essentially you're helping my mom's
sitting right there and she's terrified
and my mom is like a really sweet demure
comforting woman and no matter what like
she's like this Beacon of like
positivity essentially and I remember
saying to her and this this sticks with
me to this day
for numerous reasons but I remember
saying like Mom
am I gonna am I gonna die
and it said of course of course I expect
her to be like no honey you're gonna be
fine everything's gonna be all right she
looks right back at me and says I don't
know and that just like
you know of all the years I've taken off
of her life with the dysfunction and
pain and anxiety that I've caused that
definitely took a few off my mind just
that moment that just sobering reality
um I wound up going to a treatment
center or really like high-end Treatment
Center in Arizona they shipped me off to
called The Meadows and
you know there's a bunch of drug addicts
there but it's also for
it's like for all dual diagnosis and
multi-addiction it's people that have
sex addiction or all kinds of stuff were
there and um like basically if there's
like a rich person who gets caught
cheating on his wife or a doctor that's
prescribing themselves fentanyl or some
[ __ ] they can go there and try to like
Salvage their professional life or their
marriage essentially and um
I was like a kid in a candy store
because there's all these like silicone
MILFs walking around I'm essentially
like 18 year old jailbait right I'm the
youngest dude there don't let the [ __ ]
up uh teeth and the chunky exterior fool
you I was a pretty boy at the time I was
real cute
um you know
sidebar shout out to my homeboy Omen he
always said
I'd rather be chunky than a junkie so
we'll get into why I got a little bit of
weight on me now it's probably a good
thing to some extent
um when uh so I'm at this place and uh
I wind up seeing this
I remember the first day there when like
the guys one of the other patients is
showing me around and introducing me to
all the other people there and um we're
going into the laundry room and he's
like oh that girl that's in there she's
the hottest chick in this entire place
and I saw her and even though she had
like her hair tied back and um
no makeup on or anything and was like
looking downtrodden and it's like her
fifth day in rehab so she's definitely
don't have her weather together she was
essential uh I was like damn she is
[ __ ] gorgeous and this is the year
2000 so it's like on the tail end of the
the Baywatch era and she's like a blonde
Beach looking silicone
um
really hot chick she's like seven years
older than me and I was like heart eye
emojis popping out of my skull I was
like damn that chick's hot but I didn't
think she would ever talk to me a few
days later I'm sitting by the pool and
she like she's like on the other side of
the pool and then you know those scenes
in like movies where like the girl waves
to the guy and then like the guy looks
behind you like she can't be talking to
me it's got to be somebody else and then
you're like me and she's like yeah and
then I was like that literally happened
and she walks over we talk for like
three and a half hours straight wind up
making out now keep in mind for all you
guys that haven't been to treatment
centers the number one most frowned upon
thing in any rehab besides doing drugs
is having any type of sexual interaction
or hooking up with anyone but that's all
people are trying to do because you know
you have drugs that's like that's your
only advice you have to lean on when
that's taken away what do you have your
ins like my instinct was just sex plus
I'm an 18 year old hormonal young guy
like so you know of course I'm in this
this hot chick so I instantly fall in
love I have no serotonin because I've
been addicted to ecstasy they're putting
me on all these different drugs to try
to get my serotonin levels and my
dopamine levels stabilize in the
meantime though I have this like secret
relationship we're sneaking around the
facility trying to find like the one
place where there's no camera so we
could like make out and I could like
finger her or whatever you know what I
mean like and it was um
she was seven years older than me um and
um she was one of the original employees
of this is like right after the the.com
boom she was one of the original
employees of a company called Netscape
which was one of the original web
browsers she started out as like a
secretary made herself indispensable to
the company had crazy stock options and
was apparently worth millions of dollars
so I was like I hit the [ __ ] jackpot
this super hot chick chick has all this
money she's foolish enough to like me
because and I'm doing whatever I can to
manipulate her into liking me more
writing her poems lyrics from songs from
obscure artists that I hope she doesn't
know and I'm pretending it's my poems
that I'm writing to her and all this
[ __ ] doing whatever I can to endear this
woman to me and um
then uh
when you're in a treatment center like
that they're always trying to recommend
an Aftercare facility which is
essentially like another rehab center
which is getting a kickback from that
rehab center it's all a [ __ ] racket
it's all a business and uh she was
recommended to go to this place in New
Mexico and I manipulated the staff and
my parents to agree to send me to that
same place obviously without them
knowing that she was going to be there I
wind up um they wind up shipping me out
like before her she wound up going home
back to her family for a little while
before she went so I'm like there and
the whole week I'm there
instead of being a g and keeping my
[ __ ] mouth shut because if I just
kept my mouth shut and not said anything
and just you know
pretended to work this program or
whatever because the whole time I didn't
care about being sober I was just
killing time until I could get [ __ ] up
again any treatment center I've ever
been to it was whether it's by because
of my parents because of whatever woman
I'm with or due to the you know the
state of California
I never on my own volition wanted to get
clean ever and I would do whatever I
could to get [ __ ] up in the meantime
in between time whether it's [ __ ]
snorting drywall
um making myself pass out I tried banana
peels toothpaste if there's drinking
Listerine because there's alcohol in it
whatever like I'm I wanted to get [ __ ]
up
um however I could be the drug test I
would do it um
so I'm bragging the whole time she's
gone which before she's there and I'm
bragging to everyone like I got a
girlfriend and I think it was again like
this intrinsic need for validation like
I'm important I'm worthy I deserve a hot
girlfriend like she she really likes me
and
unbeknownst to myself I'm like it's
mainly women that are at this place and
I've become like this toxic Force within
their like recovery bubble and I'm just
like spreading this negativity and
triggering everybody finally she gets
there within an hour of beer for being
there they're like Nick you're getting
you're kicked out you're getting shipped
off to another place then where they
sent me was this place in a small town
called Prescott Arizona
called the Prescott house which is like
a hardcore pound you in the ass recovery
like they're not [ __ ] playing in the
slightest it's an all-male facility and
um most of the people there there's
people regular drug addicts but that's
like the the vast minority the most
people that are there are there because
they're fighting some type of sentence
or as a condition of their sins so they
don't have to go to prison and a lot of
them are for sex charges so there's
people that are there for there's like
this old Mormon guy who was there that
had molested his granddaughter there was
um another dude who had met a 14 year
old girl on the internet and seduced her
and had I actually looked this guy up
he's still on the sex offender registry
um
there's all kinds of like and I'm like
I'm in the mix with them and they have
these really strict rules like you can't
even masturbate there's rules against
masturbating you're supposed to hold
each other accountable AKA snitch out
people for everyone you live with for
anything you see that violates their
very very stringent protocol and
um I was like this place is [ __ ] hell
well I wind up meeting the only time you
can talk to girls and of course I'm
being labeled as a sex addict when I'm
really just an 18 year old regular kid
with a healthy libido I'm like bro I'm
just trying to get [ __ ] laid and like
but I'm a sex addict because I was
obsessed with this girl and all this
crazy [ __ ] um I'm when I first got there
I'm like using the pay phone to call the
Payphone at the other spot trying to
talk to her like you need to get me the
[ __ ] out of here here's the deal you got
millions of dollars let's run off
together and live an idyllic existence
and Mosey off into the sunset that at a
certain point she's like no this is
harmful for my recovery stop taking my
calls left me completely heartbroken and
devastated so I'm like now facing the
harsh harsh reality that this is my
existence all I want to do at this point
is get back to LA but I'm stuck in this
little Podunk town in Arizona I want the
only place you could talk to women is at
the AAA meetings and then it's on a
super monitored basis I wound up meeting
a girl there
who's in like the female version of the
place that I'm at we wind up running
away together
I like
take the little bit of money that I have
because they give you like an allowance
of like 50 a week or some [ __ ] and I
wind up saving up for a few weeks we um
start she has money too we're like
maxing out her cards all this [ __ ] we're
staying in dope fiend motels with
monthly rates wind up meeting people in
the little community over there and um
we're start selling acids start doing
whatever we could to get by and hustling
and just trying to trying to make ends
meet I actually had a job for a little
while too I was working at Whataburger
which is not better than in and out for
all you Southwestern people I'm sorry
it's not but um that was like and uh
this girl that I was in love with was a
crazy nymphomaniac to the point where
you know
she had slept with everybody in the
[ __ ] town like she couldn't have you
left this girl alone for 10 minutes if I
left and there was another guy there she
would suck his dick it was that crazy
and I was just like miserable but at the
same time I'm like happy you know that
I'm
that at least like I'm able to get high
and um but my existence is really Bleak
at that point I wound up getting an
upper respiratory infection and I went
to a free clinic to go to the doctor and
um tell the doctor my history tell him
I'm a recovering addict and all that and
this guy I remember the doctor the free
clinic chuckling to himself and he when
he was like well
huh you uh
your recovering addicts
you're probably like this
he gave me
a prescription to coding with
Promethazine cough syrup
um
thing called bar it was like a you know
pint-sized bottle and there's with four
refills I essentially spent the next you
know month or so a couple months just in
a leaned out days you know I I had
sipped syrup before
you know growing up like I knew about
like DJ Screw and Three Six Mafia and
stuff but this was like the most I had
ever been into it like that and um
I wind up
somehow someway
my drug counselor that I had had that I
was seeing back in La winds up coming
snatching me up and sending me back to
the treatment center that I was at
before after that
at that spot I wanted meeting a girl who
was from the Bay Area from a small town
named Alameda outside of Oakland and we
kind of struck up a relationship there
and I wound up moving to the Bay Area
at um 19 years old and lived in a series
of halfway houses until I finally got my
own apartment and um my
really started actively I was already
actively pursuing my dream of becoming a
hip-hop artist but that's when it kind
of when I got my own spot when it really
kicked into high gear you know from a
young age I had really really simple
Ambitions because I didn't expect to
live long I thought I was going to die
in my early 20s and I didn't care I
wanted to I welcomed death because I
figured like it would you know James
Dean die young leave a beautiful corpse
type thing
um and I had no sense of a future I
didn't care or no and I was so
narcissistic that I didn't care who
would be the family that loves me my
parents my brother my grandmother I
didn't care about the pain it would
cause anybody if I was dead and I was
such low self-esteem I kind of was like
they're better off without me I'm a huge
liability all I do is break their heart
cost them money steal from them whatever
you know steal anything that's not
[ __ ] nailed down like but um
all I wanted to do was to like wrap on a
stage and get
have people say that I was dope and I
wound up achieving that at a super young
age and I was like so everything after
that was essentially a Victory lap and
uh
you know between the ages of
19 and
38
there was feigned
feigned um periods of functionality I
had periods of success but the whole
time I'm addicted to drugs I had a
um you know I don't
I was smoking weed every day since I was
12 drinking habitually never really got
like delirium tremends or like would
shake when I didn't drink but I would
feel really agitated when I wouldn't
drink
um was addicted to all different kinds
of pills primarily benzodiazepines
that's like Xanax and [ __ ] was a big
thing for me I had a huge cocaine phase
a big opiate phase even a crystal meth
phase uh towards the end of my run and
um I think the reason why I wound up
living is because it wasn't just one
drug the whole time I would eventually
kind of substituted it addictions and
you know I had
gone through anything everything you
pretty much could from um incarceration
divorce overdosing several times being
evicted from several homes being stabbed
being shot at having hits on My Life by
different gangs and you know different
criminal organizations getting kidnapped
um been getting beat within an inch of
my life
being completely demoralized estranged
from my family
um none of my friends wanted to let me
in any closer circumference to him and
uh
eventually I just kind of ran out of
steam and uh
I had bought him so many times it was
like
right when I thought I hit the bottom
like the floorboards would give way then
I would fall down and hit another bottom
and then I was just like by this time
I'm halfway to the seventh layer of hell
and um
the place I wound up getting clean and
sober at
which was
um my sobriety date is February 3rd 2020
so that's like two years eight months
and like 15 days sober or something like
that
and I guess it's more I guess it's 17
days
um
I it was a pretty hardcore place but I I
thought prior to that it's as listed as
a facility for chronic relapsers and I
always Define myself as a chronic
relapser but in reality like I said
earlier
I've never had an Earnest attempt at
recovery I never wanted to get clean
I was just killing time in between use
and it was only for periods of a couple
weeks at a time once I was left my last
facility at age 19 it's like damn near
two two decades of uninterrupted use
and I always just thought that um
you know I I never [ __ ] relapsed
because I never wanted to stop
and uh this was my first time actually
trying to work a program surrendering
and making an Earnest attempt at
recovery and turning my will and my life
over to God and lo and behold by the
grace of God I'm still sober and you
know shortly before I got clean
about uh like about 10 months before
that I was about to be evicted from my
third apartment I've been divorced
um
my apartment was looked like it got hit
by a hurricane there's just like clothes
everywhere my you know my my bed I
couldn't distinguish if it was the dirty
mattress was soaked with my own pits or
the dog's piss I had two chihuahuas
um who I missed very dearly because my
ex-wife had them have a lot of different
dogs that exes have and sucks because no
matter what relationship I'm in
eventually
they realize that I'm not a suitable
person to have kids with or
continue on a relationship with no
matter how much they love me and they
get tired of taking care of me and the
relationship it evidently ends and um
um at that point I was pretty much you
know the crystal meth addiction was
going really crazy
um
I was just out of control and I wound up
texting this girl I knew on Easter of
2019 and I was like happy Easter and I
put the Little Star Emoji she texted me
back and for some reason
she we wound up talking and this is like
a girl that really has she woman that
has everything together she has a
master's degree is doing really well in
life is successful has a whole career as
a singer
um
comes from a good home
lives from a you know Suburban
Pennsylvania and all that and we wind up
falling in love she moves to LA with me
to kind of save my life and she
literally like cleans and organizes my
entire life I'm getting evicted so she
moves us into a new apartment
um and all she asks is that I get clean
and um I'm lying to her the whole time
saying I'm trying to get clean lying to
her about the you know I'm still popping
pills I said their doctor prescribed and
this is how I'm supposed to get off of
the benzos but they're really not I'm
hiding my crystal meth use and but she's
seeing me looking all like you know
bug-eyed and sweaty and I'm saying No
this is just me withdrawing from the
benzos like at a certain point I'm
unable to even be intimate with her
because I'm rather just masturbating
until my dick is sore and about to fall
off
um
and um because I'm taking the rent money
and spending it on other [ __ ] I want us
getting wind up getting us evicted again
we she moves us back to her family's
home out in the east coast and um so
that's where we stayed but I needed to
go back to LA because you know in the
suburbs out there it's not like I could
go to the corner and find drugs we're
like in a really almost rural area
and I also you know I had some loose
ends I needed to tie up but really I
needed to get more drugs so she flies me
back to LA and within a month of month
of me being there I wind up in this
treatment center
um which was in Texas
there's a place called BRC and it wound
up saving my life I was there for four
months
and then I was in a sober living house
for two months
then um
my fiance and I wound up moving back
there and back to the east coast and I
was back and forth since I got clean
between LA and out there things started
to go really well for me and you know I
was completely dedicated to the program
I'm going to several AAA meetings it was
weird because like when I before I went
into treatment I had heard about this
thing called
um
you know the coronavirus or whatever I'd
heard it mentioned a few times but when
I was in treatment This Global pandemic
breaks out and I'm kind of like
oblivious to it because you know the
spot I was at had no technology that we
have no access to phones uh we have
we're able to make one phone call a week
monitored by a counselor and it's only
to a person that the counselor chooses
so it's either one of my brothers my mom
my dad or uh my my fiancee and it's for
10 minutes and monitored that we have no
access to television the only news
source we have is newspapers and um kind
of hearing about all this crazy [ __ ]
that's going on but it's also kind of
like fueling my egocentric drug addict
nature like well I go to treatment and
the entire world shuts down like isn't
this like it's because of me like isn't
this great and then I got out and it was
kind of trippy but um
it was a really disconcerting transition
to make when I like got re-emerged into
society I'm kind of grateful that I did
it through a sober living house so it
was kind of nice and a little bit more
settling and gradual and um you know I
had at that time I had living a really
simple life and I was I was genuinely
happy for like the first time in my life
I remember
um
being at the hotel my fiance was staying
at near my sober living house and so
shortly after I'd got out of treatment
and there was like 140 dollars on the
floor and I picked it up and I found it
I had completely lost sight of my moral
compass but at this point I actually had
it again and I like went to the front
desk excuse me someone lost this money
and he's like oh don't worry about it
just keep it and I was like really like
but the fact that my instinct was to
return it like even right now if I saw
that [ __ ] I'm snatching it up and at
that time I'm really God is in my heart
I'm operating at a higher vibration
higher frequency and I'm just like
you know I was just like really happy
but then the ambition to get back into
the world of entertainment and get my
hip-hop career popping off again and my
career has a battle rap host and curator
you know I had all these opportunities
starting to come up and uh wind up
getting my like first real
it wasn't my first record deal but my
first real label deal where I have my
own label and um with my fiance and her
brother and I'm back in the mix with the
battle rap thing and then slowly but
surely recovery is taking a back seat
the fact of the matter is this everybody
in life
has a pyramid of things that are
important to them whether it's you know
um
God
um the family
relationship work there's a pyramid that
everybody has for me I don't have the
luxury
of having a regular pyramid my Pyramid
has to put my recovery first if I don't
have the if the the peak of my pyramid
isn't recovery I lose everything else
that's important to me and that's what
wind up happening
um things were going great I make was
making more money than I had ever made
in my life I have all this amazing stuff
going on I feel like you know my story
is an influence and a
an inspiration to thousands of people I
have all these people that are so proud
of me all the wrong doings of my past
you know not I did a lot of [ __ ] up
[ __ ] I did a lot of [ __ ] up [ __ ] I did
[ __ ] that I can't talk about because it
would incriminate myself for others as
well you know
um I don't even want to get into it all
but I can't I'd love to be honest with
you on burden myself and talk about it
but I can't I really can't but for the
most part A lot of the things that I had
done
I made right a lot of the people that I
had harmed I made amends to them and
were chipping away like I I still owe a
lot of money but you know I started
chipping away at things like that I had
a genuine relationship with my parents
which
which Felt So Good especially because
around that time when I was gone in
treatment my mom got my mom got
diagnosed with Alzheimer's disease so um
which is really painful and it's crazy
because that's the same fate that her
mother succumbed to and when her mother
had Alzheimer's my mom took care of her
like really really in a fanatical way to
the point where she'd like literally
raised millions of dollars and changed
the met with President Obama and change
National policy her and a bunch of other
people called the Alzheimer's
Association on how that disease is
treated you know what I mean and um she
you know her person coming to that fate
it was really painful but she has had
enough wherewithal and memory to know
that I was clean and that you know made
me feel so good
something I want to impress upon all
y'all is that addiction
knows no
bounds addiction doesn't discriminate
addiction doesn't care about race class
gender orientation socioeconomic status
all is that all of that is irrelevant
anybody can be stricken with this fate
with this disease people like to say
that it's not disease people like to
look at it as a choice well you know
diabetes is a Affliction as well right
but depending on what you do and how you
take care of yourself that determines
the outcome of that
it's the same thing with addiction if
you don't wind up feeding that addiction
you could use it like you know it's like
a fire hose and if you direct that fire
hose to something productive you know
you wind up
saving burning buildings and could do
amazing things in life if undirected
it's just flailing in all directions
looking like one of those uh guys those
dolls that what do they call those
inflatable inflatable uh statues outside
of buildings doing advertising right and
that's kind of like what my addiction
was but um
you know I wound up
at a certain point things started going
left
and um
the like I had some money issues came up
and I went right back into my old
patterns I didn't relapse
I never used again but I started with
the biggest part of my addiction the
biggest problem I had was honesty you
know I was been been a pathological
[ __ ] liar and as honestly as I've
been during this conversation there's
moments where it's been difficult
because it's like my instinct to just
not embellish but just say I want to
endear people to me so I want them to
have a perception of me that I think is
going to make me look better than it
really is when in reality like nothing
resonates with people more than honesty
and being genuine and um
even though I know that intrinsically
it's just like against my nature and
lies are a mechanism that's kept me safe
in my addiction in the streets has kept
me out of trouble so many times that
it's still you know something that I
struggle with
um but it's something that I wound up
going bad in my relationship again the
lives popped up again
um the volatility the um the
instabilities you know stealing and
financial mismanagement to the point
where
this my fiance who had been to Hell and
back with me thugged it out through all
these unimaginable difficulties and
unforeseen circumstances finally decided
she had enough and decided that we
needed to split up so
we split up my mother's condition
worsens and um I wind up in a really bad
situation with my career with the
company that I own
the battle rap League to the point where
like it put me in serious debt and
everything went left and got all [ __ ]
up and
here I am
in the midst of my sobriety going on
three years
and everything was going wrong and I
didn't know like what to do back in my
parents house
and
it's crazy because
for the first time throughout I I was
suicidal again I felt really bad
um they wound up putting me on
medication I don't know if the
medications what's made me not want to
kill myself because I still have really
dark days but
at a certain point
and through the success that I've had
recently with my podcasting which has
gone to the next level and wound up
getting like a permanent slot over there
and things are really blowing up and
just like the interaction and the
connection is really dangerous to let
externals
dictate your emotions whether it's
praise or criticism but for some reason
like that really kept me going and today
for the first time I realized I could be
happy even if I don't have this woman I
was gonna thought I was gonna spend the
rest of my life with there is a hope for
me I could have a happy life I could
have this new career and if I just like
really dissect all the intricate layers
of Lies this Web of Lies so intricate
that [ __ ] Spider-Man would be jealous
of it if I could cut through that and
just focus on what's real and what I
really want to do and when I say what's
real not not only being real with other
people but being real with myself and
following my genuine passion
then I really have a chance of
either getting back with her one day if
that's the path or meeting somebody new
and starting a new life and just finding
that happiness within it's not about
other people my instinct is always find
validation in others but
I can find it in myself I can find it
with God
and the fact that I stayed sober
clean and sober throughout this whole
experience and here I am now things are
finally starting to turn Corner if I had
been using
and I and I don't know how to deal with
these emotions because the whole time I
was clean I was with her so I'm like
she's like almost essentially became my
higher power that's what I was leaning
on and I wasn't even aware of it and now
I'm actually becoming stronger because I
don't have drugs to lean on I don't have
Financial stability to lean on I don't
have this relationship to lean on I have
to find this strength truly within for
the first time in my life and it's I
can't tell you how gratifying it is and
if I would have relapsed I might have
temporarily taken the pain but the way I
use if I just I can't just have one
drink I can't just smoke a blunt by the
end of the night I'm gonna be popping up
pills at best case scenario at best case
scenario I'm a wind-up messed out in a
dope fiend Motel snorting snorting lines
off of a hooker's [ __ ] and that's
that best case scenario or worst I'm
gonna be in I'm gonna wake up in Men's
Central Jail or [ __ ] dead somewhere
or in an alley and that's the real
reality in my existence I don't have the
luxury of using casually and if I had
and if I had who knows where the [ __ ]
I'd be at now
but I stayed clean through this and
things are starting to look up
what's been most surprising but
you know going through this clean patch
for you
that there is a light at the end at the
end of the tunnel and that it involves a
path that I'm choosing for myself that
I'm genuinely passionate about so much
of my existence has been based on people
pleasing and catering to the emotions of
others and is not because I'm this
altruistic I mean I am I'm a nice guy
right as [ __ ] up and flawed as I am I
have a good heart but
me being kind to other people and doing
for others it's not because I'm this
altruistic person it's because I want to
control their perception of me I want
other people to think that I'm so great
and then maybe one day they'll help me
out if I need it that it's really I'm
giving but with selfish intentions I'm
trying not to do that anymore what
what's surprising is that I actually can
be happy and I can be happy by myself
that's like the craziest thing
the Temptation is still there to use oh
the Temptation is definitely always
there I mean
I was telling you the other day I was
taking a walk in my neighborhood and I
smelt a coat of fresh white paint and it
instantly reminded me of cocaine and I
have a lot of thoughts of using
something like you the thought of using
uppers
isn't as appealing because I I have
naturally so much anxiety and I'm so
stressed up and stressed out and like
wired up as a person but the thought of
like taking some downers and just
sleeping peacefully for a long time and
that sounds amazing I'm not gonna lie
even the thought of smoking weed doesn't
sound cool to me anymore like I don't
think I would be all weird and paranoid
but just taking some pills and just
drifting off into a blissful state of
dream state
that sounds really appealing but at the
end of the day the more I immerse myself
in my recovery the less tempting it is
like I'm still around it the majority of
my friends to this day still use I'm
around drugs all the time around people
smoking weed and drinking you know when
I'm doing the podcast when I'm hanging
out and I never am I tempted
like the idea of it sounds good but I'm
never like I want to do this right now
or I wish I could have a hit I'm just
like
it's kind of crazy but no you know I
would say that the res the obsession has
been removed and that definitely can
happen if me I don't like to say this
can happen to you because I think giving
advice is really pretentious but for me
and for millions of other people the
obsession does get removed like I do I
do I do recoil as if from touching a hot
flame from the thought of using
that's great
all right Nick thank you so much for
sharing your story thank you very
interesting
wish you great luck from here thank you
thanks